marianne what pushed you to audition for
survivor
i think the thing that pushed me to
audition for survivor is that i love the
show and then i realized they were
accepting canadians and i'm like hey if
i love it so much i'm always saying let
me put my money where my mouth is so i
auditioned and here we are today
so
you just auditioned and then you get the
phone call what was your reaction when
that phone call came through that you
were going to be on the season i was
freaking out and it was funny because my
mom was at work my dad was working
abroad my siblings were nowhere to be
seen so i'm out here like having like a
whole freak out i can't tell anyone and
then i have to go to work literally in
30 minutes so like i'm going i'm booking
i go to work everyone's like marianne
there's clearly something like not right
like are you okay and i can't say
anything so i'm like i'm like i'm fine
like nothing nothing nothing really
happened nothing's of no it was so
surreal
survivor makes you a very good secret
keeper
oh yeah it's
it's it does and i'm known not to be the
best secret keeper so it's a little bit
of a balance
so what does it mean for you to be
representing canada
i think the thing about what it means
for me to be representing canada is that
it just shows how diverse canada is it's
like i think you had erica and chantal
smith from the previous season and
they're completely different than who i
am and then i think we also have two
other cast mates who are canadian as
well too i think omar and drea and we're
all completely different people like
even in like the press that you're
seeing ahead we all have different
stories and that just shows how big and
diverse canada is you have people who
are immigrants you have people who've
immigrated to canada people who have
immigrant parents people have been
living here the whole time and we're
just such a big huge not a melting pot
per se but such a diverse country and
we're all here and ready to play
no you're absolutely right toronto is
the most diverse city in the world
so
you just mentioned erica and you're
leading me into my next question because
she has set the bar for canada in one
last season
what kind of pressure does erica's win
put on you
you know what
the seasons were played like filmed back
to back so i didn't even know who erica
was when i was playing so i was just
living my own little life feeling like
i'm canadian bubba
you know and now still coming back and
then seeing that erica won as a canadian
i'm pumped like you go erica take it
home and like i'm from the gta too so
i'm like you know what like i love that
toronto representing you know when i'm
traveling i say i'm from toronto because
people don't know where ajax is so i'm
loving it i support it full-heartedly
and you know what she took it home so
that means that i don't have to
i love that expert
that was a lot
people know where ajax is it's just east
of toronto people in toronto know where
ajax is people outside no and people
west of toronto don't even know where
ajax is people on the east know what's
happening about the west but people of
the west don't care about the east it's
kind of rude
it is a thing i will admit so how do you
prepare mentally physically and
emotionally for survivor
so what i really did to go prepare
physically was that i started working
out so i went from like zero times a
week to like one and a half times a week
because you know you got to be at your
physical peak and when your physical
peak isn't that low pretty easy to go up
only and nobody's put up for mentally i
really prepared and emotionally i
prepared where i have a therapist so one
thing which i really did was i really
wanted to go and work with my therapist
to figure out who am i as a person like
what are my tics what are my triggers
how am i perceived by other people how
do i process things so when i come onto
the island when you have literally
nothing like no food no shelter like
nothing i know how i might react in that
space
now you noted one of your pet peeves is
anything that disrupts your sleep
so
do you know what happens on survivor
because i think it's well known that
sleep is a challenge so
the game plan going into this
my game plan going into it was that i
was just praying that i wouldn't be
sleeping next to someone who snores okay
and
there was someone before the game
started i'm trying to sleep in all here
like dying like where they're sleeping
and i'm like god please please please
please please i don't want snoring but
what i knew was that regardless i
decided i was going to sleep as far away
from everyone and just take that l if it
came to strategy if you wanted to talk
in the night because i'm like i need my
beauty sleep to function so i always was
just like i'm just going to sleep far
away from everyone y'all can do whatever
i'm sleeping far
now you talked about your mother and how
she overcame so many obstacles in her
life and is someone you aspire to be
like what was your mom's reaction when
you finally were able to get a hold of
her and let her know that you had been
cast on the show oh my gosh
so actually when i started about
thinking about applying for survivor my
mom literally had never watched an
episode so like as a lot of people knew
she was like i'll just take you back to
the village so but then when i was in
the process she started to watch it
she's like
you want to do that are you sure and she
got so concerned but she knew that i
really really wanted to do it so when i
told my mom she was so excited we
actually got indian that day my mom
hates takeout she's always like miriam
why would you buy food when there's food
at home so that's how you knew she was
really supportive because like we got
some indian food and it was really
really exciting and she was so excited
she kept on giving me tips as well too
what were some of her tips
marianne think before you speak
that was the biggest tip i am a big
talker so she thought my mouth would get
me in trouble
that's a great tip to have uh jeff is a
television icon what was it like when
you saw him for the first time
oh
my gosh i kept thinking i was dreaming
you know because he's right there i'm
right there it's like we're on the same
island it's like if i i could probably
run and jump him if i wanted to you know
i wasn't going to but like he was just
that close so it was so surreal to see
him in the flesh like
so surreal i like even looking back at
it remembering i'm just like oh my gosh
that was that was so surreal
and if you could describe this season of
survivor in three words what would they
be
oh my goodness the season of survivor in
three words best season ever because i'm
on it that's why